women are more emotional wouldn't they
be the ones to
initiate coercive control more so than
men then
because coercive control is an emotional
thing no because men know that women are
more emotional so they know that they
will react more to emotions than they
would to physical and that's what i'm
trying to say women react more to the
emotional than they do to the physical a
woman can be hit 50 to 100 times until
he's messing her up and telling her you
can't wear this you can't do this you
can't go here you can't see that person
and then eventually she's like hold on
wait you're controlling me but she
accepted the hitting she accepted the
race
wait that's coercive controlling
behavior is the guy telling you you
can't wear something or go somewhere
yeah if the person is isolating you from
your family
and your friends and telling you i don't
want you hanging around this friend
he's giving you a reason telling you
because it's this that that and the
third but then you end up you're stuck
in the house you can't go nowhere you
can't speak
today a woman right sending a voice note
to her ex-partner she is no longer in a
relationship with this man he is so
controlling that because she has
children with him he's annoyed because
she met a friend
outside of her why why is she dealing
with him like he's because he's right
i'm starting to question the kind of
people
he's setting a boundary okay he's
setting a boundary he's saying i don't
want you to do this do that do that do
that do that and she has the choice i
can either keep dealing with him or not
deal with him so i don't think that's
coercive control like i've i've been
with a guy that was that was pretty
controlling but i'm never going to say
oh this is kind of coercive controlling
behavior no no let me finish
i'm never going to say oh this is
coercive controlling behavior boohoo
poor me i'm going to say okay i picked
that guy that was my bed i laid in it
and i left when i was too bad like i
just i can't stand excuses it's just
like we pick who we date but then pearl
isn't that isn't that a confidence thing
it's not no i'm i'm pretty unconfident
to be honest i'm pretty insecure and
it's just it's just that i had a father
that didn't let me
make excuses for goddamn everything
maybe that's what it is then maybe
because saying it's an excuse can i just
connect but you are because you keep you
keep offering now but the the reason why
this you're saying that the partner is
sitting boundaries right yeah if he she
has the children 24 7 right she has well
not 24 7 but she has most of the care of
the children so he will pick and choose
when he has the child or the children
let's just say right and then she for
whatever reason is with this one child
out of let's just say the five just to
be anonymous but let's just say they
have five children okay and um
she's got one of the children and she
wants to go and meet her friend there is
nothing more nothing less there is no
issue with it it's not somebody that
she's sleeping with right she's gone to
meet the person she's been respectful
enough not to take the child into the
house she stood outside of the house and
had a conversation with the friend who
is a male and now the guy is saying hold
on wait but you took my child to this
person
is she not allowed to do that simply
because she is he is he threatening her
too
he's been threatening her but you're
saying it's keeping us personal it's two
nuances like this exactly do we know
this happens there is so many women that
deal with this and this is what i'm
saying but it makes it difficult when i
said there's so many women that choose
that you're saying they choose it in
that choose that yes but those are the
same women that have died because
unfortunately they chose that so does it
make it acceptable well it doesn't make
it no it doesn't make it acceptable but
we should take accountability for the
men so what the women that are dead
should take accountability they
shouldn't have stayed you go to that
that's shocking it's sad
career you got him far too extreme like
that's that's sad
so when i said to you sorry pearl to cut
you so when i said the situation that
happened and i said oh i could have been
killed i could have added that bit to
make it more like i could have run into
debt dramatic and be more dramatic no
one is saying it's right what you're
trying to say is that it oh i just want
to say you're not hearing what i'm
saying you're listening and hearing it
all falls down to us
she's not saying that it's right but
only you can get yourself out okay well
the thing is how are you going to deal
with that see the thing is how are you
going to deal with that situation that
this person keeps doing it because the
police ain't going to do nothing
the poor ain't going to do nothing
so what you're going to do about it you
can only
mentally strengthen yourself right so
what she's basically saying is that the
ex they're all excuses it doesn't mean
it's um which is using the word excuses
that this is being that we justify for
this thing to keep continuing so you and
yourself have to do things and get seek
the help but we need to seek the help to
eradicate that saving continuously
spiraling out of control hundreds
understand what i'm saying no one's
saying
that oh it is right because this is
wrong it is
hang on hang on the difference hang on
one second
so i think we misquoted coercion um
coercion isn't like you you can't say
that it's coercion if someone's telling
you what to do or where to go it's only
coercion if it's under the threat of
violence
right so like no no i just looked up the
definition so yeah but men
understand
no one's coming to save us
i'm saying like so when you're talking
like this it's like
you've always got
someone to save you
men don't have no one to save them again
they had to save themselves so when so
when so so when shay saying
you got this you got the courts are
going to act like that you've got the
police are going to act like that right
who you got to rely on but did he not
just say that there's no one come to
save you and you actually have to figure
it out for yourself so that's so that's
what you're saying men accept that men
yeah but with women it's always an
excuse so was that oh but someone else
should have done something but i was so
in love like he he was nice at first so
then that kind of defeats the whole
objective when we asked when you asked a
question earlier of should men protect
women or should they not
no that's a different context like see
like i feel like sometimes when we're
making a point you bring up something
completely like off topic
and then and then it's like i need to be
right so then it goes into oh it's not i
need to be right i'm just trying to like
figure out exactly what is being said
here because that was just that was a
different context of if a woman is in
need of trouble
should a man and then she went on to say
and she was an example of them talking
about equality but so there was a that
was a different context to what we were
actually talking about now if the woman
cannot get herself out of this situation
and she is continuously abused does she
not then need help to get out yes and
i'll tell you what okay i'll tell you
from because it seems like it's getting
there if they have brothers
uncles men in the family and i've said
this to women before they should go and
contact those guys because men won't
abuse when there's other men that are
going to stand and protect because you
use the word early about protecting more
bullies and men that do that they do it
to women that are vulnerable and some
women don't go and tell those men
because they don't want that man to get
in trouble
if it's really affecting your psyche go
and contact the men around in the family
and what if they don't have those men or
what if those men that's why i said
actually stand up for them when they're
vulnerable what do they do is my
questions and then it's easy
like they need to accept and they need
to all of that but then in reality
it's like obviously i i cannot save the
world but i have said to this specific
woman you need to get out of the scene
you're saying so you're saying that she
hasn't got no male figure whatsoever in
our whole family that she can speak that
feels the need to protect her enough
clearly because if they were going to
protect her enough so many people around
her have seen it so many people around
her have commented on it but they
haven't done anything about it i know
and that's why i just see it
she doesn't leave right is that good she
chooses not to leave correct no she's
left
but he won't leave her okay yeah he
won't leave him like does he threaten
her drag her like how does she get back
to the stretch it's constant like oh
because you went to see this friend of
yours they are not in a relationship
does he pull her scream does he get
violent with her no
okay so okay so
violent but it's mental no no but it's a
choice
someone is continuous
if someone is continuously telling you
you're not even in a relationship with
them but the person is continuously
saying hold on to you she's choosing
torture you're doing that you're doing
this and it's mentally affecting them to
the point where they're constantly
irritated they're agitated they're angry
they're fed up mm-hmm it's it's mentally
so she should be listening
she's already how does he how does he
know that she's going to
hang out with a friend or whatnot if she
doesn't tell him i've never known him
it's to do with the children he
questions the children
okay well the kids can say the kids can
after after it happens
the kids can say what they want to say
but i've never i've never been in this
situation but i've witnessed it from
someone that is very very close to me
and i've told them why don't you
just like stop talking to them you're
not in a relationship with them you
don't have to check in with them you
don't you literally if it does not
concern the child you do not have to say
anything to them and that's a choice and
that's what that's what everyone's
saying it's a choice yes they may
question the child he may say well you
went to your friends blah blah she has a
choice to
either feed into what he is saying
get the things from him that he's saying
take it in or just say yes i did the
child is safe we we hang out outside
boom bam boom
and she doesn't she
doesn't have to give her
engagement you don't have to engage in
the team
because it's emotional yeah
it becomes difficult because it's
emotional the thing is i've been there
right i've been involved in emotional
situations where i've
looked at my behavior afterwards and be
like oh sorry man you shouldn't even
have got involved but you get drawn in
or you get drawn out right that's what
we get but
what you have to understand is that
if time after time after time you have
no self-reflection and you have no um
no introspection as to how you keep
getting into the same situation and the
same result keeps them happening
it comes that there comes a time when
you now have to say what am i doing
why i keep getting myself into the
situation and the same result keeps on
happening because you
keep engaging in something that you
actually don't need to and maybe you
need tools to understand and to work
with as to how not to engage in that
situation anymore but it is still
your uh it's still your behaviors that
are getting yourself in situation
because how many times can someone
constantly slap you in your face
without you saying hang on a minute
do i like this no okay so what am i
gonna do to actually change this if you
continuously get slapped in your face
all the time then after a while
say the first three times that's on you
because you are now choosing to engage
in that behavior do restraining orders
or how are those easy to get in the uk
they're pretty easy to get in the us oh
yeah
yeah
sorry yes for women yeah so there is so
what is stopping her from getting a
restraining order i don't think it's so
restrained
is there anything stopping can i just
get yes or no is there anything stopping
her from getting one no okay so it's
again it's a choice
you say i mean maybe you need to just
tell her that because if you're saying
you feel passionate about it because
what she will come back and say is yeah
but what happens is that shut up
okay this is what you need to do you
just get restrained in order and shut
your mouth and you're right and i think
and and i think sorry i think a lot of
women do not have the men around them to
say shut up and get on with it because
the bottom line is if you keep coming
back to me as a man and i keep hearing
the same thing repeated over and over
and over and over again men are people
who want to get things
done so when you come to even if you've
got a man and he can you come home and
you start saying this happened at work
that happened at whatever the man's
gonna end this goodbye okay so we're
gonna do to stop it because he's trying
to find a solution and now if you are
not if you are not trying to find a
solution i'm not trying to hear you and
i want to add to this once you let some
also people allow this or women allow
this to come in this case and i've heard
from other women not just myself as a
man realized women some women actually
like that that's all that passionate
stuff that's all of that whole kind of
fiery toxic and then you know he's crazy
over me somebody loves me at the same
time but they wouldn't tell you but
they'd like to come continue to complain
about it but they generally enjoy it as
well because it means that they still
care so like be as you said jessica said
earlier about how did she know that
she's meeting someone if you know the
type of guy
maybe she i'm not saying she's because
i'm i'm just trying to say some from
experiences and erin if she keeps
allowing this to happen also there might
be a possibility she enjoys it happening
but i'm not saying the mother of your
child don't know what you're doing day
to day
the mother of my child don't know what
i'm doing day to day
right but she couldn't know but the
thing is in him but your
your child's father's not involved with
the children you said right because
you've cut it off right our our mothers
of our children are still involved we're
still involved with our children but
they don't know they don't need to know
what we're doing day to day because now
we're getting you too involved to get to
and now you've got too much control over
certain things you don't need to know
what i'm doing day to day again it's to
do with the emotion i feel like women
actually want to know what's going on
they it's like
this is a flip side now this is your
friend now again
can i just say this like i said earlier
it's about control and accountability
that's all it is
if you let a man know what's going on in
your life yeah you want him to know you
want it you know women if we want to
hide stuff
i'm not saying if we want to have stuff
we can hide it better
it's true if we want it at the forefront
we'll put it at the forefront and with
i'm not going to say all women a lot of
women they know that they want a
reaction that reaction means we've got
that that man's attention regardless if
we like him or not we've got control of
him you know in a way we might not like
to admit it but it gives us a sense of
power over him and like i said earlier
accountability
and what did i say
accountability and control these are the
two main things that in all of those
situations what we've spoken about i've
sat silently and listened
these are the two things that come up
every single time do you know what you
just said there though about women
wanting a reaction yeah i'm sure you can
testify and i'm sure as a man i can
testify that when somebody wants to
control when somebody is a control freak
when you don't give them the access to
control you yeah a lot of the time it
builds up they're building it up they're
thinking oh my god i don't know what's
going on and then they just they're
waiting for that one chance
to get a chance to control you right and
a lot of the time me
whether it be men or women a lot of the
time you have to understand i purposely
i'm sure you do i purposely tell you
to contact me via email
you don't ring my phone don't text me
contact me via email because what i'm
doing is i'm keeping a boundary for a
certain reason because if i let you in
too much you now feel like oh
well
i can now control some things here no
you cut you set that boundary from day
one well okay
i just want to say because
that you have a level of maturity about
you you will do that but other men they
don't clock onto that part so they'll be
texting on whatsapp voice note in social
media think about it women can write
paragraphs on social media stories
saying how this guy did this showing
pictures and all kind of
kind of stuff but then when it comes
down to the direct communication and
accountability part for themselves they
can't do it they will sit on social
media think about these stories on like
these funny you know blog sites or
whatever they will sit there and
formulate
images and paragraphs a whole storyline
but then they'll say it's the man's
fault
women women know how to tell stories
they will purposely put themselves in a
situation where they could take a
picture and say oh look at this like
look at this bad man outside my house
and write a whole storyline so
to get people on side with them do you
get what we do because they are one so
can we establish like speaking to the
mic sorry can we establish that
basically when it comes to like abuse
and recording yeah
it's a situation where
if
men and women did record
it probably would eliminate all of this
stuff because we just wouldn't act
inappropriately that's what paul said
earlier that's what yeah that's what
people said because when you think about
it if she was recording everything that
he was doing and when you're saying
about coercive control and behavior and
this is the thing it's like because of
controlling behavior doesn't mean that
they're threatening all the time you
could do something they'll let it go
don't leave it and act like oh they
might manipulate you and
emotionally mentally whatever it is and
then after like a certain block of stuff
like it might be like six or seven
things then they'll be turning up at
your door banging down your door and
doing this and doing that so it's like
when it comes to question control it's
confusing but again if she had recorded
that
and
actually acted on it and did what she
needed to do it probably would have
stopped just the same way when i
recorded this person
and gave it to her i needed to give it
to it stopped and he started doing it in
covert ways the more i even reported
that the covert eventually he gave up
because you now can